You know what Mickey, we need to make.
This channel more popular. We need more views.
More likes.
Okay. How about this? 10 lit swear words.
Spanish. Okay.
Well, how about this idea?
Tell your boss to go to hell in 50 different languages.
What do you mean? No.
Way. That would be the biggest video on the whole channel.
No way.
Oh, wait. You mean Norway? Sure. Let's do that. That'll be super powerful.
Hello.
Everyone. Welcome to the Lang focus channel and the, my name is Paul.
Like we just decided a moment to go.
Today's topic is the main language of Norway Norwegian,
a language that in many ways feels familiar to speakers of English and other
Germanic languages like Dutch and German. As I said in my video,
want the North Germanic languages of the Nordic nations Norwegian as a North
Germanic language, along with Swedish and Danish,
as well as Icelandic and Pharaoh wheeze by around the second century,
CE prodo Germanic,
the earliest common ancestor of aldermanic languages had begun to branch out
into Western Eastern and Northern dialects. And by the eighth century,
CE the Northern dialect had developed into old Norse spoken by the seafaring
Viking tribes over the next 600 years or so old North developed into the various
North Germanic languages of today.
Norwegian today is spoken by around 5 million people, mainly in Norway.
As I discuss at length in my video on the North Germanic languages,
Norwegian is very similar to neighboring Swedish and Danish. And in writing,
they share a high degree of mutual intelligibility, but in speaking well,
it depends differences in pronunciation and an extensive dialect continuum that
spans all three languages make intelligibility difficult.
In many cases that dialect continuum exists within each of those three countries
as well inside Norway,
there are dialects that vary greatly from each other in most countries with lots
of dialectal variation. The standard language is a unifying force,
a bridge between the various dialects, but in Norway,
there are two officially recognized standard languages [inaudible] which means
book language and Nina nosh,
which means new Norwegian during the centuries long union between Denmark and
Norway, the Norwegian elite spoke a form of Danish with their own Norwegian
pronunciation. And Danish was the written language of Norway.
After the end of the union in the 19th century,
a movement for a new national language began.
Some people wanted to base the national language on Danish with minor
adjustments, which resulted in a written form called Greek small.
Others wanted the national language to be more distinctly Norwegian than Danish.
This resulted in the creation of London, small,
a more conservative written form,
which was created using elements of various rural Norwegian dialects.
This was the precursor of new notch. The Norwegian linguist,
he bought Orson created long, small.
He examined the multitude of rural Norwegian dialect,
especially those of Western Norway,
looking for the elements that each dialect had preserved from old Norwegian and
use those to create as traditional a form of Norwegian as possible while still
being based on its modern dialects. Why did he focus on rural dialect?
Because the urban dialects had been influenced by Danish while rural dialects
were more purely Norwegian, but it's small, still exists in its original form,
but was mostly replaced with a slightly updated version called [inaudible] lung.
Small was also replaced with a slightly updated form called new NAUSC
book Mol and Nia nosh are more similar than small and land small,
where there were plans to merge them into a single standard called some
nauseous, but that never happened. So now there are two standards today.
Local governments can choose one of the two standards as their official form and
26% representing around 12% of the population have chosen Nina.
NAUSC mostly rural communities in Western Norway around 37% have
made book mall official and 37% are neutral, but in those areas,
book mall tends to dominate,
but everyone is also required to study the other standard as a secondary form.
These standard languages are mainly written and when it comes to speaking
Norwegians usually use their own dialect, even in formal situations.
First let's focus on boop mall and later we'll look at me nosh in comparison,
pronunciation and orthography,
there are a tremendous number of different accents in Norway.
And even when pronouncing standard book mall,
they will likely pronounce it in their own accent.
All ways of pronouncing Norwegian are officially considered correct,
but let's focus on the pronunciation of Oslo,
which sort of serves as an unofficial pronunciation standard continence.
The pronunciation of Norwegian consonant letters is often different from their
English equivalent G is usually pronounced good.
Gun, but before EDI.
I I, or why it's pronounced. Yeah.
Yay. And the letter J.
Is also pronounced that way. Not like.
J
R is usually an alveolar trill at odd. This is.
One sound that varies greatly throughout the country.
It can also be an alveolar tap and another accent.
It's a uvular fricative like, hah,
the letter K is pronounced before N where it would be silent in English Neve.
So unlike the English word knife, this actually makes sense.
K is also associated with some other sounds.
The combination KJ is pronounced char like in the English word.
Hugh Shula.
So as K before E I, I, or Y.
She knew, but these.
Days it seems that among young people,
there's a growing tendency to pronounce these as HSA.
And I understand that this is the source of much controversy.
The letter S also appears in some combinations to represent the sound HSA or
approximations thereof, SJ. Sure.
S KJ, shoo and S K before E I I,
or Y she,
some consonant letters are silent in certain contexts.
There's the letter G for example, in words,
ending in IgG or EG dial-in and before J
yes.
And in some other words like mourn D is sometimes silent.
For example,
after R L or N or after a long vowel,
goo H is silent before J and V.
The letter T is silent in the definite form of neuter nouns,
like whose and in the neuter pronoun there.
And V is usually silent after L at the end of a word hall
along consonants, double consonant letters,
and clusters of consonants are pronounced as long continent.
They are held longer than a short continent, for example, huh.
Now compare that to this word with a short continent hall.
This distinction occurs only in stressed syllables.
There's also a distinction between short and long vowels.
When a syllable contains a long consonant, it has a short vowel.
And when a syllable contains a short consonant, it has a long vowel hall.
They differ in length, but sometimes also in quality too, for example, Oh,
short, Oh, stop and long. Oh, book.
I first short cyst and long C
this vowel is long because it's in an open syllable with no consonant at the end
E short E 10. And Longie PIM,
there are some other vowels that are different from English vowels.
The Norwegian Y sound is like the sound E but with rounded lips,
he lease,
you represents a sound between OU and E who's.
This letter is like the sound air, but with rounded lips,
it's also worth pointing out two more vowels.
This letter used to be common in old English, but as rare in modern English,
it's been a part of Norwegian ever since it developed from old Norse,
it represents the sound app as an English set,
but usually comes after our shod. It's sometimes pronounced like a,
this,
this letter represents the sound all similar to the vowel in the English word,
yawn, the way it's pronounced in many British accents store.
Most words in Norwegian have pitch accent. There's a pitch accent,
or a tone change on the stressed syllable.
There are two different tone patterns. Tone. One is low high.
It starts on a low tone,
then moves to a higher tone in the stressed syllable tone. Two is high,
low high. It starts high, but.
Falls then moves to a higher tone in the stressed syllable.
The mud Berlin.
You can see from the two examples pitch.
Accent can indicate differences in meaning,
but the tones are different depending on the dialect and are not crucial in
making yourself understood.
But ignoring pitch accent will result in a distinctly foreign accent grammar.
The grammar of Norwegian is not terribly complex,
and it's a category one language according to the American foreign service
Institute,
which puts it in the category of languages that are supposedly the easiest for
English speakers to learn. That doesn't mean that it's easy to learn.
It just means that it's not as difficult as a lot of other languages.
And that specifically for English speakers, let's look at a basic sentence.
This sentence means I haven't eaten anything today. Word for word EDS.
I have not eaten anything today.
The word order in this sentence is exactly the same as an English Norwegians.
Basic word order is S V O.
And we can see that the verb is conjugated in the present. Perfect.
In the same way, it is in English with the auxiliary verb hall,
which means have in the present tense followed by the past participle of the
verb.
Speece.
And also notice that just like in English,
the negation word comes between the auxiliary verb and the past participle,
but Norwegian verb conjugations are even simpler than they are in English.
There are conjugated the same, regardless of person or number.
So for each tense, there is only one form.
Speece is a regular.
Verb.
So it's a good example in the present tense [inaudible] you can see that even
though the pronouns are different, the verb forms are all there.
Sam SPI Sid also in the simple past, there's only one form USB sta.
And there's one future tense form visa.
There are additional perfect and conditional conjugations that correspond with
those in English. Each of them having only one form,
one minor pain in the backside is that Norwegian nouns have grammatical gender
feminine, masculine, and neuter. For example.
I give in the meaning a woman in mom, meaning a man it's field,
meaning a mountain.
For announced that are not inherently masculine or feminine,
like man or a woman, the gender of each now needs to be memorized,
but notice the gender specific indefinite article that comes before each.
Now there are also gender specific, definite articles,
definite articles attached to the end of that.
To be not that a woman Mon the man, she.
These three genders are used in more conservative Norwegian.
And in ne now using three genders is required, but in book mall,
you can choose to treat masculine and feminine announced as one gender common
gender in the common gender,
both feminine and masculine nouns use the masculine form.
Remember that people who use boot mall as their written language may still speak
dialects that are different and may use all three genders in speech.
Even if they use two in writing, let's stick with the common gender for now.
Now let's check out the forms of the notes.
Kevin, the nerds.
Meaning women, men, meaning men.
Meaning mountains is the same as the singular form.
Neuter announced like this that are only one syllable long.
Usually don't change in the plural, but you can tell that it's the plural.
If there's no article second, look at men.
This is an irregular plural form with a change in the vowel STEM Kevin.
This is a regular plural form. Plurals of all genders usually end in ER,
like this as for the definite plural forms.
The ending is which functions as the definite article.
Been in LA, the women, men are men.
The mountains let's make those nouns.
We just saw a little more interesting by adding.
And it literally a beautiful woman, insect mum, a handsome man,
[inaudible].
A tall mountain or a high mountain.
The adjective to a certain extent agrees with gender.
A T is added to the end of most staff directives when the noun is neuter like
this T at the end of and when announced plural.
And he has added to the end of the adjective in both the neuter and common
genders.
Need liquidated, beautiful women sector, men handsome men, who are you feeling?
Tall mountains or high mountains.
Also when a noun phrase with an adjective is definite,
there's an E at the end of the adjective, but something else also changes.
There's a different definite article. Then the beautiful woman,
then [inaudible] the handsome man,
the tall mountain or the high mountain. And in the.
Plural Dean is lecture when the beautiful women,
[inaudible] the handsome men. [inaudible].
The tall mountains with the high mountains, both genders, Coleman,
and neuter take the same article and the same endings on the adjective.
And the noun.
Adjectives are also used to create adverbs by simply using the indefinite
singular neuter form of the adjective. Like, Hey,
they usually have a tea ending though. There are some exceptions, Hey,
as an adverb means loudly as in, at a high volume.
Now that we've examined some basic features of Norwegian,
specifically boot mold,
let's look at mold and new notch side-by-side and see how they're different.
Let's start with a sentence we saw earlier in book mold,
meaning I haven't eaten anything today.
Yeah, hard. It gets BS, Loyola, the color shift and awkward duck.
These sentences don't seem so different, but there are a few differences.
The first person singular subject pronoun has a slightly different form,
ye egg. Similarly,
some of the other subject pronouns have different forms.
Next notice that the negation word is spelled differently. Isha.
Now notice that the verb for eat is different in ni [inaudible] is also
used, but this option, it is more specific to new NAUSC.
And also notice that the word for something or anything is different. Newer,
new Google.
Obviously the words in book mold and new nosh are often related,
but with slightly different forms in spoken dialects,
there are additional variations. Some of which resembled Nia notch more,
and some of which resemble Luke, [inaudible] more, here's a sentence.
Meaning she had a bad dream.
Who not. Then one drum who had the [inaudible].
Notice that the third person singular feminine pronoun is different.
Also the masculine indefinite article is slightly different.
You can also see that the word for dream looks and sounds a little different
than them.
Nia NAUSC tends to preserve more old diphthongs from old North.
Then boot mall in this way, ne [inaudible] is more like Pharaoh, wheeze,
and Icelandic. Then book malt or Danish or Swedish. Here's a sentence.
Meaning they like to drive fast cars.
[Inaudible] [inaudible].
First. The subject pronoun is slightly different.
Next notice that the infinitive forms of the verbs are slightly different should
show her in bookmark.
The infinitive of most verbs ends in an unstressed eat in neo-Nazis.
The vowel can actually be either E or a with a being the more conservative one.
Now notice that the word for cars ends in ER,
in book mall and AR in
[inaudible] [inaudible] has a tendency to use AR when boop mall uses, ER,
though this is not always the case. Here's another sentence.
Meaning crime is increasing due to high unemployment.
[Inaudible] criminality. [inaudible].
Notice the different spelling of the verb,
meaning increase including the ER and AR endings that we just mentioned as well
as a diphthong appearing in the new nosh word. Good.
Go next. Notice the difference in the way of saying do too, we'll get,
do not good enough. This way is more characteristically [inaudible],
but a new notch. You can also use the same expression as in book mall.
[Inaudible].
In book mall. There is also another form. You do this,
but it's less commonly used. Notice the differences in the words,
meaning unemployment.
Lisette, Elbit slicer.
The word in malt contains the suffix head,
which is used to turn adjectives into nouns.
But new nosh generally avoids this suffix because it reflects the influence of
Danish. Ni naush has a degree of linguistic.
Purism aiming to avoid lone words from Danish and German.
And one final pair of sentences.
Meaning falling in love is common among young people.
[Inaudible].
Notice that the first word in either sentence has a different ending ne tends to
avoid the book mall ending Elsa, which forms a noun from a verb. Next,
we see a different spelling of the word, meaning common. And again,
we see the ER ending in book mall where it's AR in new NAUSC,
as you can see, Norwegian is a very interesting language.
And if you speak a different dramatic language than it probably seems very
familiar to you in many ways, it's also a very accessible language,
especially if you focus on boop mall like most students do,
but when you dig a little deeper, there are many,
many dialects with countless variations for you to get used to as well as new
NAUSC the other form of standard Norwegian.
So even though it's an accessible language,
it's also a language with a lot of depth for people who choose to go deep.
The question of the day for native speakers of Norwegian in any of its
varieties, which form of Norwegian do you most commonly use in writing.
And how about in speech?
Can you easily communicate with people who use other varieties and for other
people,
what do you think of the situation of having two standard versions of the same
language in one country?
Can you imagine such a situation with your own language?
If you enjoyed this video,
then be sure to check out Lang focus on the various social media platforms.
And as always, I want to give a special thanks to my Patrion supporters,
especially these ones right here on the screen,
who are my top tier Patrion supporters. So many extra special,
thanks to them and to everyone. Thank you for watching and have a nice.